do that it's called the Gooch oh ok segi
how did he not break his tailbone I
tried hi welcome back to stuntmen react
they were here with Aggie to Silva now
Guillen has worked on a couple of
projects if you happen to be active on
the subreddit you may have seen the my
hero academia short that I did with
Chris Cohen that was you also have that
amazing video he's also happened to be
in things like I don't know Black
Panther Captain America Civil War he was
Leonardo for Michael Bay's Ninja Turtles
I got to be a transformer my five build
stuff will be really happy are you
mainly specialize in fight scene sir yes
I'm a big fight guy grew up doing
martial arts that's the stuff that
really like hits my soul awesome I
almost jump in Jackie Chan gotta take
the fast way fanny pack we're not taking
because you know the Italian people are
fighting Oh implying that in real life
he could actually get out of his like a
hotel room that way his Airbnb looks
like he lands on his butt and bounces
right he does he does announce do how
would you be everything ok segi how did
he not break his tailbone I tried so
it's like a 10-15 foot drop dude he uses
his feet he lets his feet take the hit
first but how do you not break your
ankles man dude he's not trying to stick
the landing he's just using it together
nothing Ament him off of his ass that's
a magic trick he hopped over the rail to
I'm sure I don't want us to you know
he's in pain oh my god from standing on
my feet to going down like that would
hurt so bad see this was like forever
change how I operate in the rest of my
life I'd be walking with a cane for the
rest for these guys it's a literally a
throwaway joke in the beginning right
tire it's like opening no big deal
dude this is one of my favorite fight
scenes of all time think that move is so
cool back boom
wow so much style 3 I know dude my
favorite is the double kick yes look
hold it they hold a shot - yeah they
stay the big spin hook come on Jenny
heavy candles man put you out first you
think you're under cranking the footage
a little bell definitely so under
cranking for those of you not heard the
term before most films playback at 24
frames per second but if you record it
at 22 frames per second and playing back
at 24 it moves slightly faster oh this
is it this is it yeah boom oh I like the
fact that he gets hurt it's okay to get
hurt and they they play with that and
they make the comedy of that but like
for this fight isn't like super clean
and that both of them have some salt in
it right so this is full contact right
here
[Music]
these weren't you see you see the see
the pads yeah he's wearing a ho goo tech
mundo of guard it's fun because you can
see it yeah you enjoy it you appreciate
it so much more when you can see it yeah
I feel like with a movie you're supposed
to be capturing an image a special image
you know and like if you're gonna show a
fight scene capture the fight scene if
you're not gonna show the fight scene
like oh it's not about like it's not a
fight scene then don't worry about it
but like if you're gonna put a fights in
your movie you need to show it it's just
the camera moves are perfect in Jackie's
movies yeah
like the way they follow the action left
right left right left right biggest
thing is time how much time are you
willing to spend on your action do you
have the patient or not those kind of
scene when you see it in two minute or
one second you fall check it good it's
not good you can do it this is kind of
like a homage to Bruce versus Chuck
Norris yeah you know Bruce has to loosen
up and start playing to his rhythm and
change the rhythm of the fight in order
for it to work for him
oh look at that man just get the
lawnmower out and on the back shoulder
hairs so much testosterone this is so
cool watching him just warm up right and
now he's all glistening and sweaty in a
trance I love that oh no Chuck this
hurts get off my chest
it doesn't come off his hand look the
point that the foot the chamber you just
saw we just saw Jackie do that so it
turns out that all those sounds that
they make Bruce seem like he's making
aren't him that's somebody else's dub
over him are you serious yeah he doesn't
do he doesn't do that really no he'll
make like yells and and screams and
stuff but it's never sounded like that
it always sounded goofy right
actually no he uses sound to displace
people so like you can faint somebody
out with not just movement but with the
sound so like a cognac ah with your jab
and you go ha they react thinking that
the jab is coming because of the sound
and now you have an opening I never
thought about using audio cues to start
somebody off in your swings so know that
your your reactions are faster to sound
than they are to your side yep so that
that was his play but then they headed
the wall you gonna try bouncing out oh
look at you oh oh and that's when you
completely get somebody on your rhythms
and once you have them in your rhythm
you start playing them like a nice
little instrument he's like don't go for
it
don't do it I'll kill you ah am break
and here's the remorse consequences of
war you could have taught Taekwondo at a
strip mall somewhere in the Midwest we
will we come such a long way in fight
scenes and movies now this seems almost
just a little slow not very spectacular
very paced out he want to really give
the feel of what a real fight is
like it's a game of chess a real fight
is about 10 minutes long do you guys
size each other up you're looking at and
you're like we about to do this y'all
both like yeah we're about to do this
about there's that quick moment of of
beautiful chaos and then boom we
separate it's like okay that didn't work
this works let me chart now let me come
back in if you can find a way to tell
that story of that fight like that it's
so fun to actually really see that I
mean those make the best fight scenes
when there's an actual story right for
how I guess not modern the pacing the
fight scene is the storytelling this
fight scene is very modern yes in fact
it's better than most modern fighting
I've teleported all the way we're here
to my desk to let you guys know that
this video is sponsored by a rake on
they have a very special 15% off
discount code for you guys more at the
end of this video let's go to the next
scene
[Music]
dude I love this approach ya know the
street come at me bro
like Enloe got the kicks oh yeah Conan
relax
oh shut down look at my kicks that son
is so sick doing action so how do you
jump like that from a crawling position
oh I see you guys feet under yeah walks
away this guys are on it I also heard
that they show up and basically
choreograph it right on the spot and
then film it immediately after that's
probably why it took them two months to
shoot that make sense do that
there's the wire so there's a line it's
gonna help him flip back it's called the
Gooch so they they have the pic point is
here oh so he's like gathering yeah the
person taking hit are they the ones
who's like actually dealing with giving
themselves all the momentum they need a
lot of the times yes so I'm already kind
of pre-loaded and I have to make it not
look like I'm trying to do a move or
anything like that just has to be full
taking the reaction and performing it at
the same time guys watching all these
Jackie Chan videos be very excited about
next week's video and that is the Jackie
Chan Olympics that's right if you've
been watching this channel for a little
bit now you've probably seen the other
celebrity Olympics that we've done we
did Tom Cruise we did Indiana Jones and
now hello yes
does Jesse speak Clinton how long have
you been waiting for this
as I signed up for martial arts in the
ninth grade guys I am ready to go I'm
claiming the title of honest Jackie Chan
you think you're just gonna walk in here
and take it dude but this skill set
absolutely when I was when I was in
ninth grade I used to wall run every day
during recess when's the last time you
called your uncle it's been it's been a
very long time
subscribe to find out who becomes Cora
Cruz Jackie Chan
[Music]
so this like this had a ton of praise
back and it came out this was a
game-changer this reminded me that you
actually have to be an actor you have to
be a performer in order to do stunts as
well it's not just being able to go out
there and hit the ground or throw a
punch you have to be able to perform it
like this director somehow gets his
actors to do anything yeah and then this
actor in particular also will do
anything they just do not give a crap
about the personal safety or well-being
or even it's just like their public
image or anything it's like such true to
the iPhone step man taking out toes oh
yeah he has a knife in his back I do
such a good job managing the crowds and
the oh yeah and then waiting around like
actually doing stuff yeah it gets so
real when your takes to get this long
everything gets real yes I love that
about it I'm afraid to get tired and
what a great shot to cut to also such
good filmmaking yeah across the board
the reason why I love the fight the most
is because there are moments where he
isn't he isn't in in control he isn't in
power and he's having to regain that
power back and fight his way through to
get to his objective it's good as mike
really saw basic things I like anybody
can get yeah and one of those is camera
movement basically if the protagonist is
walking forwards they're winning if
they're walking backwards they're losing
but this the scene in particular the
cinematography if it really sells that
because the camera is moving right other
words move right little bit more it's
super basic like fundamental language
but when used with everything else being
more sophisticated on top of it yep it's
really powerful so old boy was remade by
Spike Lee I don't want to do I have
it's a really great fight steam it's
almost like a little Hollywood mouth
yep so they're trying to do the whole
like hey we haven't cut again but you
know they're missing the point yes
the missing the point of why the first
one didn't cut the original old boy it's
a one-er because it shows you how much
willpower that main character has that
he will push through the pain and the
desperation and exhaustion because
there's a intent and there's a purpose
in the fight it's okay for you to do
that a lot of the times now we just have
it for ego oh you know you saw that one
oh yeah we did it for spectacle you know
this there's no exhaustion nothing
drives home the point of
misunderstanding by having Josh Brolin
get stabbed at the end of the fight yes
because you get stabbed in the middle of
the fight to show your your willpower to
get out it's over already thanks bro
that's not what it's supposed to be I
need to see the internal fight is that
he's not hurt now look he's totally not
hurt he's like whatever like this
alright stabbed in the back I get
stabbed in the back every Thursday kind
of itchy there's one critique I heard of
the film that was I thought a very apt
critique Spike Lee was too faithful to
the original to entice people who saw
the original to watch Spike Lee's
version but he's also too faithful to
the original to entice people who didn't
watch the original to watch his first oh
so nobody saw nobody saw it so I didn't
see it if you guys would like to follow
GE ask some questions anything like that
if all them on Instagram it's GX the
Silva yes
EXO Silva and of course if you enjoyed
the show you know please consider
subscribing and please leave a comment
for any other cool fight scenes I love
finding some really obscure stuff please
let us know in the comments below it's a
great way to know what's out there you
know the best part about ye was the set
okay hey guys you might be wondering
what I'm doing here in this episode well
you had two stuntmen on today right well
I've done my fair share of stunts
I thought I'd pop in is that a reference
yeah hello yeah it's like a stunt thing
that's not why I'm here I'm here to tell
you guys about today's sponsor Drake on
headphones that's right for about half
the price of other premium headphones
you can get a pair of these and you
don't have weird plastic stems hanging
out of ears and you didn't spend way too
much on them so they look cool that's
the first thing second thing if you
don't like the black and blue guys you
can give them in different colors
there's a whole range of colors on these
guys they're also about the same
qualities other premium headphones about
half the price which is a talking point
that Jake almost took for me but I
snatched it back did so huge thank you
to them for sponsoring this video and
all you got to do is go to buy rake on
Comm slash corridor crew and you'll get
15% off your purchase get yourself some
phones guys come on thanks Jake
[Music]
brakes this this with a roundhouse yeah